in unserem video heute zeigen wir euch
wie man in deutschland jemanden anruft
maria welche situationen zeigen wir
gleich einmal wie wir einen arzt anrufen
dann einmal wie wir einen freund anrufen
einmal wie man pizza bestellt und einmal
wie ein wie man in einem restaurant
einen tisch bestellt die wichtigsten
situationen jetzt mit maria los geht's
[Musik]
ja hallo hallo bin ich da richtig beim
lungenfacharzt müller ja richtig bin ich
da richtig bei lungenfacharzt müller ja
sehr gut
ich wollte einen termin machen für heute
ich würde gerne einen termin machen ist
da noch was frei heute geht es leider
nicht so könnten aber gleich morgen in
der früh kommen
morgen wäre noch einen termin frei
ja das wäre mir wichtig weil ich habe
totale schmerzen in der lunge gerade ich
wenn ich ein atmen dann tut's auch im
rücken weh meint sie das sehr akut ja
das kann ich von hier aus jetzt nicht
sagen haben sie eine bereisung vom
allgemeinarzt haben sie eine überweisung
ja genau da ich heute morgen der hat
nicht weitergeleitet an sie okay dann
wie gesagt kann ich ihnen morgen 39
anbieten ich kann ihnen morgen 9 uhr 30
anbieten
perfekt das erleichtert mich total dann
würde ich mich freuen
super und sie sind die frau wallis bin
ich und sie sind wie ist ihr name ok
perfekt dann sehen wir uns morgen 39
perfekt vielen dank gesehen
auf wiederhören
hallo hallo peter
wie geht's dir ich gebe mir ganz gut wo
bist du gerade in berlin
wie geht es dir wo bist du gerade
wo genau hat cassano li na ja da bin ich
jetzt auch grad oder mehr
was hast du denn heute noch vor
vielleicht noch ein bisschen basteln
kochen was hast du denn heute noch vor
was willst du denn kochen
ich habe hunger naja mal sehen was meine
frau ist sogar so da mal geklickt hat ja
eine frau ich auch schon lange nicht
mehr gesehen wollen wir nicht zusammen
essen wollen wir zusammen essen gehen
ich weiß nicht ob das so das wahre ist
alles klar
ja gut dann vielleicht ein anderer tag
um anderen tag ja machen wir vielleicht
schönsten vielleicht ein andermal
pfingsten das passt mir auch noch da
habe ich auch noch nichts vor okay gut
dann rufe ich wann anders noch mal an
ja mag das und testen dann melde ich
mich noch mal
hey wie gehts ja völlig zu hören es gibt
mir was machst du gerade so was machst
du gerade
eigentlich bin ich gerade auf dem weg in
ein paar tagen wollte dort ein bisschen
relaxen
ok ich wollte eigentlich was mit dem
wachen hättest du noch spontan zeit
wofür worum geht's ich wollte eigentlich
zum see fahren weil gerade noch so
schönes wetter ist aber ich könnte auch
in den kader kommen was hältst du davon
wenn du mich liebst klar auf ein bier
kann ich immer kann ich immer ein laden
ja dann warte ich darauf dich alles klar
dann sehen wir uns gleich ich freue mich
gut bis gleich dann sehen wir uns gleich
bis gleich
ja hallo hallo ich würde gerne drei
pizzen bestellen und ein salat
ich würde gerne eine pizza bestellen
okay zum liefern oder zur selben abend
zum liefern bitter ok welche therapie zu
sonst an die nummer 43
die 22 und die 7
ich hab jetzt vergessen mit zu schreiben
was es das vierte größten trapezen und
ein salat den hatte ich auch noch nicht
genannt das war die nummer 14 als nummer
14 okay er ist der mozzarella darin oder
käse weil ich bin laktoseintoleranz ja
wir drehen kann ich aber raus lassen
alles klar perfekt vielen dank rising
joghurt oder balsamico haben sie auch
senf dressing
nein leider alles klar gut dann nehme
ich bei nico okay gut machen wohin soll
in die form wirkt müllerstraße neuen
ministranten ok gute halbe stunde super
vielen dank immer wieder hören
da ja hallo hallo ich würde gerne einen
tisch bestellen für heute abend
ich würde gerne einen tisch reservieren
kann ich für heute abend noch einen
tisch reservieren einen tisch bei mir
zuhause oder ach nee ich würde gern
einen tisch bestellen bei ihnen heute in
der pizzeria ok million personen kommen
sie denn
angedacht sind jetzt vier es könnte aber
auch sein dass noch ein fünfter dazu
kommt wäre das ein problem ist kein
problem dann machen wir mal sechs
vielleicht kommt ja noch jemand welche
namen des aufwandes auf welchen namen
geht das alles wie schreibt man das wls
wie schreibt man das okay weil es sechs
personen wieso wollen sie denn kommen 19
uhr geht das noch ist da noch was frei
19 uhr ist perfekt das ist vor unserer
rush hour um wie viel uhr wollen sie
denn kommen ja okay also 19 uhr weil es
hier hören vielen dank
maria wie war es total schön wir haben
richtig tolle schauspieler getroffen
hatte wir hoffen ihr konnte etwas lernen
und wenn ihr demnächst mal demnächst mal
wo anruft dann wisst ihr wie ihr das tun
könnt wenn ihr noch weiter deutsch
lernen wollt jetzt dann probiert doch
unsere app ceiling aus darüber freuen
uns sehr und ihr euch wahrscheinlich
auch denn die app hilft euch dabei die
deutsche aussprache zu üben und schritt
für schritt eure stimme selbst
aufzunehmen uns selbst zu evaluieren und
eure aussprache schritt für schritt zu
verbessern
danke dass wir bei was man gerne wir
sehen uns ganz bald wieder nämlich schon
am sonntag
und meine telefonnummer ist 0 1 578
123456 auch das merkten sehr gut
stimmt das habe ich schon öfter gehört